um you've had some pretty big moments in
terms of just like people acknowledging
the movement acknowledging you as you
know just I mean obviously makes postage
of [ __ ] uh shout out Meek man Snoop Dogg
of recent like what's what's been like
one of the more crazier things that like
kind of made you like pinch yourself
like damn I was [ __ ] in prison you
know seven years ago like now
so-and-so's on my [ __ ] like this [ __ ] is
wild
yeah that happens a lot and but what I
do is I just I'd be like shut the [ __ ]
up let me think about it stay humble
what's the next joint yeah because if
you get too wrapped up into them what am
I doing for rollout for this next
project where did it not go what didn't
I do I'm saying and I've had
two children born you know and you know
what I'm saying in the last three years
I've had two children born so wow well
congrats yeah not same baby mom two baby
moms yeah yeah I got three kids yeah so
you know I just had two in the last you
know I'm saying because you got two
young ones right now that's that's why
yeah yeah and my oldest son he's playing
you know football soccer how's your
oldest son it's ten oh nice little
little dude now man football and soccer
man once they hit like eight they become
like little dudes low-key
I think anything before that you really
look at it but like damn like I gotta
watch what I say in front of you now
because you really be knowing about [ __ ]
yeah it's definitely right now at this
time in my life my music is starting to
connect to my home life because my I
have a child old enough to understand
stuff so and that's important too
there's some explaining to do yeah no my
I have an eight-year-old who is going on
30. a lot of these dudes ain't there for
their kids a lot of these dudes like
they're lit but they're kids they're
[ __ ] 37 year old kids right they got
kids out there they don't take care of
their kids there's no way they're taking
care of their kids because I be with my
kids so I know there's no [ __ ] way
that a lot of these cats really have
that and I wouldn't really sacrifice
that relationship with my kids if I got
anything if I got to get rich slower
then I will you know I'm saying I'm
still gonna grind I'll just sleep less
that's my that's my trick that's amazing
you know I see you do it too work-life
balances and salute to everybody who
don't I mean don't get it twisted that's
there are a lot of 37 year old children
running around here but you know and I'm
not in terms of just how they live right
but I'm not saying oh just because they
don't have kids that they're [ __ ]
children I don't mean like that no so it
is that they don't take care of their
kids right there's people out here take
care of your [ __ ] kids that's what
I'm saying yeah you know
you know my baby mom makes it easy too
though you know what I'm saying it's
important man it's important to have the
right person to like understand your
mission especially being an artist like
they just somebody just call home today
a relative
and said that like
you know he just landed in a nuke and a
County Jail up
and the guards got my [ __ ] on YouTube
with the with the speaker with my shits
playing on YouTube and the cell block
right now what the [ __ ] the dudes are
going up to the cell like yo that that's
your family that's your people throwing
food you know it's like that right now
because I really came in heavy like you
know I'm saying I put a lot of people on
a lot of people put a lot of people on a
lot a lot of people wow Massachusetts
Jersey New Hampshire Delaware
Pennsylvania all-wheel you know back
then so my relationships some of those
people that you know I had these
relationships with you know we're all
out of the streets now but some of these
people know me and you know each other
now you know I mean yeah we know we
wouldn't [ __ ] each other I have that
relationship with like all these these
people
you know what I'm saying I you know so
and it's not all from drugs you know I'm
saying it's right it's from just being
well being solid back in the day it
really was but you know those
relationships turn into other things
people ended up places a lot of people
dead a lot of people in jail some people
work at [ __ ] in the scope yeah you
know what I'm saying that's crazy man
you know that's my path and I'm still
not where I want to go but my character
is on a beam